Sure, sure. That's a great question. So I would say, you
know, just as a, as a caveat, that really depends a
lot of the type of problems any given data scientists are
working on, the type of questions you're, you're looking at. For me
personally, a lot of the questions that, that I look at
and a lot of the things that interest me, tend to
be fairly high level and somewhat loosely defined and I mentioned,
looking a lot more at the social aspects of how people use
social networks. And a lot of topics like
that, sometimes the most useful thing is really
to just get a broad and qualitative understanding
of, of the data you're looking at. So,
two of the most valuable techniques I found
for that are clustering. There are various approaches,
k-means clustering, hierarchical clustering. And then other dimensionality
reduction techniques or things like principle component analysis, PCA.
One, one thing, just speaking very specifically that
I found very useful is the combination of
k-means clustering and PCA. So if, if you
generate clusters and then use PCA to take the
most, meaningful vectors to plot those clusters on,
you can often do a really nice job of
reducing dimensionality of a data set and understanding,
the significant differences between clusters in a visual way.